as we go to our next game global warning
according to NASA 2016 is on track to be
the hottest year in history beating the
previous record holder 2015 climate
change appears to be turning into a
global crisis kind of like dabbing or
putting kale and salads you're not
supposed to eat kale by the way it's
like comparsa you guys stop eating it
it's not it's not good so take your kids
to see the snow for the last time then
get to higher ground where you'll be
safe comedians I would like you to give
me as many global warming survival tips
as you can in 60 seconds and begin
Steve dry and jerk your turds to eat
later the guy who'd made the guitar gun
he probably knows how to do that points
to Steve Dave pretend it's not happening
alright boys yeah
[Applause]
Steve suck up to Elon Musk alright boys
Jay get used to the taste of your own
urine
yes thanks Steve
get off her G alright boys Dave load up
on SPF 4,000 all right points Jay learn
to breathe carbon dioxide yes points C
surround yourself with fat slow people
Chris
J
I'll fatten up your kids to use as a
raft
yeah well spikes to your Prius for when
the world goes for on mad Mac yeah